Gregory Alba is the name of this guy
right here
transgender what's your name Jessica
Luca Tuerto hell a homo sapien creepy
game show host this video that was sent
to us I think what this video is about
okay yeah here's the description and
perverted seventies game show host tries
to kiss all of the girls who are on the
show
sounds like my kind of show this sounds
like something that I would have done a
couple years ago and now I amateur we
just watched the video where Jess just
cried like a little like Brazel just
bawled this is embarrassing play no
laugh at her at all time while she was
trying ahh so I'm like right Jess we'll
watch a fun video to cheer you up
need to laugh yeah you need it they made
it I'm I'm okay not emotional I was
almost gonna call you Laurie
how can I miss Oh every easy you're both
very pretty [ __ ] child you have green
eyes honey they're not blue now don't do
that that's a kid no you talked about
getting married and having
don't what what do you do when you're 11
years old okay where do you go anyone
home from school each other okay okay do
you hand out kisses Jennifer no no no
likes to give lots of hugs and kisses
what is sister doing here's a child
molester can I say that today I'm gonna
kiss I can't have one
oh my god even if I say it whisper in
your ear that Alison I still can't have
a hug and a kiss well ease you can't win
the show then I don't get a hug and a
kiss ow
ya hear that ya hear that that's a good
answer
you what is this guy doing you shy can I
have a little kiss please no the top of
the show I'm sorry about your right
answers you give out kisses though don't
you Sam you know you don't - yeah okay
we got Stephanie and Rader the big
family kiss I couldn't get that kiss
earlier
what is happening right now
that was that was also disgusted by the
older woman kissing him did you see that
he was like I don't want it he didn't
want that oh these are like little kids
like little little kid my god have times
have changed
they're like when he successfully kiss
you here some people look at me like you
did it man it's like we used to root for
pedophiles back then that was like a
legit pedophile that's mortifying I so
buddy never let my child on that no so
no I mean I was a child on the show sure
I wouldn't give it any kiss but with my
parents I've been okay with it no no no
way and if I had a child and my child
kissed this guy would I been okay with
it probably not no I wouldn't mmm I
wonder what they're winning he's pouring
his it was like watching kids get
molested that was really um disturbing
it was like watching children caplets
that's so horrible like the way these
kids were responding was like I really
don't want to do this yeah like no
that's like do you don't have sex no
okay
jump on it you know you just repeat it
like every conversation I've had with
like every girl in 2008 yeah thanks
sorry the thing about is anything
clearly times have really changed I was
watching the movie spotlight Mel have
you seen that movie yeah London and yeah
look movies thing about kids getting
bullets to the priests yeah I was
watching spotlight recently and it was
shot is I grew up in a Catholic school
for from 1st to 8th grade so it's like
to hear this information and I remember
when like that's when the scandal was
really becoming like really out there
and then like carnivals like coming in
my church I'm like speech and everyone
like it's not as bad as people make it
out it's like it's true like this the
signs of affection and stuff especially
for what men could do now there's no way
now a guy can get away with
and I talk show today all right some
game show whatever Wayne Brady
no oh my god yeah
never it'd be different though if it was
a girl like if Jess was doing that's a
little boys little boy to be very
excited they'd be like kitty like well I
don't know
well they I don't know II guess little
boys oh well you should try it out
sometime get it on camera okay good for
reaction I'm like looking at girls being
traumatized oh they're totally
traumatized like somebody's like
especially but once you've seen what
you're kind of into it yes all of them
say no almost all of them say no it
forces it dirty old man and then he like
tries to sneak that kiss in there I mean
he's just a dirty old man he is a dirty
old as soon seem like an adorable thing
you know what it kind of seems like they
could be an adorable thing if it was
like have you ever seen the office no
never mind
this this conversation thought there we
go anywhere productive since you haven't
seen my reference I'll get on it and uh
but I this this little girl there's one
that I thought can be a younger version
of you oh yeah that could be you that
yeah what that's that thing the blonde
that child who deserve to be kissed by
this other man lucky lady I want to see
a documentary of all these women growing
up so that's their mom sitting next to
them yeah and that's their mom see next
time in the mom apparently it's
acceptable you know like I don't like in
the 50s like when men would cheat woman
would find out and they wouldn't say a
thing it would be like a cute thing if
it happened few times this season but
it's like every girl it works like this
is just kind of showing a what woman had
to deal with 45 years ago just how
different it was for to be a woman back
then you know because already like
before the 70s it was really rough ER
and then around that time it started
getting a little better but and now it's
better than then but seriously like
there's there's no way now that this
would be at all allowed to even be on TV
this would be the front page of I don't
we use or I can't even imagine what
would happen to this guy
what would I don't know what what did
this guy I don't know who is that I
would like to know who he is I mean I'm
pretty sure he has a YouTube channel
Tyrone Magnus cutie
Conan O'Brien this vote jeez this really
pisses him Oh Oh big deal
whatever you're adults wait are you kid
no wait harder well that was fun I
appreciate you guys sending that our way
um I needed to see this so I can share
this with friends at a party yeah
because this will make me popular when I
have a party I want to have like videos
like this playing on the TV like a
compilation it got creepy videos of
older man how many people just yeah that
one no one day exactly deer eyes change
color mm-hmm they were a different color
last time I saw you were they
yeah probably depends on like what I'm
wearing - they just adjust they just
that's pretty cool times they're like
green more green sometimes are more like
yellowy e-gold yeah you got kind of gold
back snake eyes thing going on or that
kid I have a kiss no you real kids it
just look like it no I don't wanna
[ __ ] kiss you copper my see my kisses
it's Nina
sighs is our hour let me see your eyes
you do have similar eyes now I'm gonna
think of you every time I hold a copper
oh yeah so furry
well I was pointless ago subscribe
please
yes subscription buttons woohoo I've
always been comfortable at something you
did subscribe jess is part of sweet each
YouTube channel I did a video on there
once I might return again if they ever
invite me stay tuned
which they have invited me but I just
keep saying now cuz they keep trying to
do this weird [ __ ] that this guy does
constantly trying to just get it I'm
like Jess my net cut the [ __ ] right now
we are professionals
I'm not to be taken advantage of for my
sexy looks and where she hasn't
Instagram a YouTube channel
check it out but that's her in real life
constant